l'inflation qui affaiblit les collectivités
locales et qui tapent aussi le portefeuille
des Français avec la nécessité pour les plus
précaires de se rendre au resto du coeur ou
dans des épiceries solidaires elles permettent de
faire des courses pour seulement 10% du prix de
vente en magasin un sacré coup de pouce pour les
familles comme à jouer les tours ou c'est rendu
Aurélie Renaud rue Pasteur les clients ont pris
rendez-vous pour faire leurs courses à l'épicerie
solidaire fruits légumes épiceries salées et
sucrées produits d'hygiène les bénéficiaires
ont accès à l'épicerie après un suivi par une
assistante sociale 204 il y a quatre personnes
au foyer donc bah elle a le droit à temps pour
pouvoir tout en sachant que bon bien sûr c'est
pas vendu au prix du commerce c'est vendu voilà
donc on a une base tarifaire et on va entre 10 et
15% du prix du Commercy katia a 50 ans elle élève
seule son fils de 13 ans elle est en recherche
d'emploi et ses dépenses sont plus importantes
que ces ressources Katia fréquente l'épicerie
sociale depuis deux mois elle y obtient une aide
pour remplir son réfrigérateur mais également un
soutien moral ben moi je peux pas faire de courses
en dehors finalement comme je suis déjà tous les
mois je suis à découvert d'un certain somme
donc du coup non non je paye que 3,50 € ici
et on a on repart avec des sacs plein ça m'aide
aussi avoir personne dans les mêmes difficultés
finalement donc moralement ça aide les stocks
proviennent de la mairie de Joué-lès-Tours les
dons viennent aussi de la Banque alimentaire
mais ils sont de moins en moins nombreux en
effet la Banque alimentaire a de plus en plus
de bénéficiaires l'épicerie étant en bout de
chaîne elle doit trouver d'autres solutions pour
remplir ses étals l'option faire participer les
commerces locaux comme ceux du centre-ville
je sais pas il leur reste 5 kg de tomates il
me dit non demain ça n'ira plus voilà est-ce
que vous venez les chercher donc il faudrait
qu'on ait un système comme ça donc ça c'est
à l'étude normalement ça devrait se mettre en
place assez rapidement ce jour-là 34 personnes
ont pu remplir leurs sac de course des achats
à prix symboliques pour nourrir une centaine
de personnes sur deux ou trois jours merci